the bee  pupa are stored at the bottom so to  collect them  i have to cut through the hive  they just pierced that calm and honey's  just dripping out  i catch it with my bamboo container i'm  just trying to get as much of that honey  as i can  [Music]  my final job to reach even higher  and scrape the honeycomb from the rock  oh my god i'm just covered in honey and  bees  and i'm sticky everywhere  [Music]  i think we've gotten all that we can get  okay  [Music]  that's getting the honey the hard way  my hands just ache from being stung but  this whole thing is just solid honey  and this the bottom part of the comb is  wax  and pupa none of this stuff is going to  go to waste  we have a taste of our prize i am just a  sticky mess  but  [Music]  no it is amazing  the sweetness of this honey is like  peach flavor like never had honey  like this at all  [Music]